I was a graduate student for many many
many years and as I was about to go off
and do a postdoctoral fellowship an
astronomer at Berkeley had a great idea
he'd been taking note of the work that
had been going on at NASA Ames and their
interest in searching for
extraterrestrial intelligence and the
early papers that suggested that radio
telescopes were good tools and he said
oh gee UC Berkeley has a radio telescope
and he understood enough physics to know
that it's possible to take some of the
signal from a radio telescope and
amplify it and do different things with
it and you don't hurt the primary
observer so he thought well we can just
steal a little of the signal and and we
can look for engineered signals rather
than Astrophysical signals I was a
really clever idea of a way to get a lot
of telescope time inexpensively but of
course he had no money and so he went
scrounging and somebody gave him this
old computer penny said well well what
do i what do I do with that and they
said oh you know Jill used to work on
that she's still around maybe she can
help you so he came to my office and he
gave me something called the Cyclops
report that was an engineering study
done at Stanford and NASA Ames and it
talked about how you could use radio
telescopes to search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and what I
got out of that was this aha moment I
said you know for thousands and
thousands of years people have been
asking that priests the Philosopher's
whoever they thought was wise what we
should believe
about whether there's life elsewhere and
now in the middle of the 20th century
suddenly we had some tools and we could
do an experiment to try and answer the
question and I thought oh wow
I mean I'm alive at just this moment in
history have this opportunity to try and
answer a question that people have asked
forever and how could you not so yes I
remembered how to program that computer
and I began working with this group and
I got hooked and I'm still hooked
when I was growing up television was
very very new and there used to be these
Saturday morning cartoon shows her kids
there was also Flash Gordon right
and I watched Flash Gordon
sipping through space and with three
guns and things and I thought that was
spectacular and I suspect that had a lot
to do with just setting up a worldview
for me so that later when I walked on
the beach with my father and it was dark
it was the Florida Keys this guy was
very dark and my father taught me about
the constellations and I looked up and I
don't think there was ever a time when I
didn't just assume that those stars up
there were someone else's sons and that
on some other Beach on some other planet
there would be a small creature walking
along with their parent and gazing at
our Sun in their night sky and wondering
whether we were here just as I was
assuming that they were there so from an
early time I had always thought about
the fact that it would be possible to
have life on planets around other stars
detection of an extraterrestrial signal
indicating someone else could happen
tomorrow
it could happen ever I mean we actually
don't know the answer to the question of
whether we're alone we could be the only
intelligent species in our galaxy if not
the universe that is the question we're
trying to answer certainly the
exponential increase in our technical
capabilities is um is breathtaking to
try and predict what it's going to be 50
years from now it's pretty darn near
impossible in fact there are probably
technologies that we haven't yet
invented which actually might make a lot
of sense for interstellar communication
and so I guess the best plan there is to
to stick around long enough so that we
get smart enough to invent that and then
start using it in our SETI searches
along with keeping the radio and the
optical going because they're not bad
ideas either